Eddie once wants me to tell my story so
just tell it briefly so the reason I
started studying nutrition at the age of
20 which is 40 years ago 1977 was
because I reached the time in my life
where I was sick and tired of being sick
and tired all the time I was chronically
ill for the first 20 years of my life I
had all kind of messy problems that I
won't get into but at the age of 20 I
was also sick of going to doctors and at
the age of 20 I recognized that what the
doctors were were giving me doing for me
prescription drugs was not only not
helping me I was actually getting worse
in the long run and I wanted to know how
to get better and unfortunately there
weren't any real doctors that I knew at
that time not like dr. Joe Grasso who's
a real doctor but I was seeing doctors
that were little more than legalized
drug pushers all they ever did was you
know here's you here's here's a drug for
this symptom here's a drug for another
symptom I was I was I was sick and tired
of taking drugs I was sick and tired of
of going to the doctor I wanted to know
how to be healthy and what I could do to
be healthy and our family doctor had
nothing to offer me nothing to offer me
and I came to understand over time why
he had nothing to offer me because in
medical school you don't you know you
don't learn about health you study
disease and you study drugs that treat
the diseases or surgical procedures but
health is not a subject that doctors
learn about in medical school and it's
very important to understand that so be
very careful who you trust and what you
buy into and certainly medical doctors
have their place in urgent care
emergency care immediate care but I
decided that in order to be healthy I
was going to need to take responsibility
for my own health and the only way I
knew how to begin to do that was to
educate myself and I started studying
nutrition and the main reason I started
studying nutrition is he said he wants
me to wanted me to say I was sick and
tired of being sick and tired all the
time
at the age of twenty and so my main
motivation for improving my nutrition
was to have more physical energy but
actually before I experienced that the
very first benefit I realized was a
lifting of the brain fog that I had and
I didn't even realize at the age of 20
that I actually had brain fog until I
started experiencing something different
in the way of mental clarity until I was
20 years of age my favorite foods were
pizza ice cream fried chicken candy fast
food burgers with french fries soft
drinks this all this kind of fake
garbage food I was putting into my body
and my health was really a reflection of
it my basic teaching about about food
nutrition is if you want to be real
healthy then eat real food and real food
is simple food that does not come with a
label with a list of ingredients no
Eddie you brought all fake food you know
it's okay so that's that's fine too you
do Show and Tell with what fake food is
but where's the real food well I have
some real food that I brought with me
I'll be showing you at the end of my
presentation here but well I hope I hope
there's nobody here who has any of these
fake food items in your home because
you're you're not going to nourish
yourself with any of this stuff this is
you're gonna burden your biology with
any of this stuff ya know you you you
may have you may have a a momentary
pleasant experience in your mouth you
know your taste buds might like some of
this this fake food but none of this
stuff is going to be pleasant for your
your liver your kidneys your heart your
lungs your brain your nervous system
your immune system no the rest of you is
going to suffer you know it's a huge
mistake to eat as if your taste buds
are the most important part of your body
and the corporate dominated commercial
food industry is kind of programmed all
of us to be more attentive to taste in
price and convenience and for many
American consumers the the most
important the most important aspect of
the food by far which is the nutritional
value is an afterthought if it's a
thought at all for many people so well
then you need a need they need to to to
be educated they need to watch Jim
Marlowe's appearances on the Dean show
and Eddie himself I told Eddie the other
day he's bidding he's becoming quite the
nutritional evangelist I mean he's
making some very very powerful Dean show
videos having to do with helping to wake
up people to freeing themselves of the
the bad habits of consuming fake foods
of various kinds you know and I I think
that's the proper way to think of it is
you're not if you're if you're currently
eating any any fake food like this when
you when you subtract this from your
life you're not giving anything up
you're freeing yourself of bad habits
and you're allowing your your your
biology to realize a higher level of
health and you're creating the
possibility of realizing a higher level
of health possibly even realizing your
full health potential at any time in
your life you know most people in this
culture learn to accept the very low
level of health as long as they feel
okay as long as they're not acutely ill
as long as they're not in acute pain or
discomfort they're satisfied okay you
know the direction of our life force
energy is toward healing and health our
body has a god-given intelligence and
capability to know how to be healthy
our body wants to be healthy it's always
trying to be healthy if you cut yourself
at heels you don't even have to think
about it the body has a god-given innate
intelligence and capability to be
healthy but this health that I'm talking
about is not realizing magically we need
to get our nutrition and the rest of our
self-care right enough in order to
realize the health potential that is
within us
you